the National Health Service is getting
better we made the decision the NHS was
special the NHS the NHS the National
Health Service the NHS is under pressure
in every part of the United Kingdom it's
a question that keeps being asked how do
we solve the ongoing crisis in the NHS
what can be done to fix this
is a big question and one which has
potentially many many answers there are
some big challenges facing the NHS today
the number of beds it has available for
patients is the money being invested in
the Health Service going to the right
places we have an aging population and a
broken social care system there are
Workforce pressures including
Recruitment and Retention the low staff
morale and the care and Welfare of
healthcare staff the pressures on Mental
Health Services and a backlog that has
been turbocharged by the covid-19
pandemic
999 mode
ultimately it comes down to this what
does the public need the NHS to be and
is it offering the level of service
required if not how can it again huge
questions with no simple answers
thank you for having
us that the NHS needs reform prime
minister Rishi sunak made reducing the
NHS waiting list one of his key pledges
for the next couple of years back in
November 2022 Health secretary Steve
Barkley also outlined five priorities in
the short term for the NHS they were
employing more staff for NHS 111 and 999
focusing on urgent and Emergency Care
tackling delays in discharge from
hospital improving access to Primary
Care and investing in technology to help
Labor's Shadow Health secretary were
streeting recently has had some strong
words to say about the National Health
Service
NHS is in crisis the biggest crisis in
its history he said the NHS was in
existential crisis and pledged his party
would train more staff use the private
sector to bring down waiting lists and
introduce Fair pay and conditions for
workers
it will have three definitely and two
possible discharges there was once a
time when politicians claimed the NHS
was the Envy of the world that doesn't
seem to be the case anymore and people
are looking overseas for answers to this
crisis we want Scandinavian quality
alongside Singaporean efficiency so what
does this mean some people want to
follow some European health models where
patients pay some money towards
treatment the former Health secretary
Sajid Javid says some patients should
pay to see their GP or for Ed visits but
others like the former labor leader
Gordon Brown won that this would create
a two-tier Health System where the
poorest would be worst off this is not a
new conversation people have been
talking about NHS reform for nearly as
long as the service has been around but
it is struggling more now than it has
ever been and no short-term Solutions
are going to fix it long term
well-funded planning is needed something
that has been difficult to guarantee in
these turbulent political times